hello and welcome to this video this is
my see my point I see okay we get what
can I do and maybe I can play ball have
done so for quite a while doing is with
37 this time now look at 85 but this is
also an interesting line yeah it takes
with the night it's not too dangerous my
96 was supreme move basically and this
isn't every wouldn't play move against
nie bede to you don't want a knight on
c6 yeah right okay it's not a big deal
we just transposed to a well known
position each five is interesting that's
basically a prophylactic move against
the against white um playing the night
and go for at form which is now I mean
yeah hi less interesting and attractive
as she has weakened himself so much so f
is not a move that i would expect now he
might sue play it but it is far less
attractive with the age horn being
played beginning yeah he still does it
yeah he's weakening is squares here
tremendously III in particular and now
I'm threatening one III immediately and
also i might just take here and i think
i will as he has to recapture with the
piece which gives me control of age five
you cannot take with the pawn so here
the question is 95 on water maybe this
and then not suffice so that i can
recapture with the beep on
it looks nice increasing my control of
age five the half-open be file might be
handy whoa why would he weekend himself
alone looks a bit strange maybe 25
immediately what's even better you could
try um try to put the Queen on to see
three so that 85 is hanging okay yeah
maybe I should have played g6 early i
have to be able to play 95 that's not a
necessity the smooth night five but
probably would have been interesting to
simply prevent prevent all this okay
here i wonder if fi this something i
should play it might also week in my
position quite a bit yeah i do this i'm
not sure because the book has some
purpose them we can do the beep horn
zone
you really want to play Queen c3 have
would be really nice for me the Queen
trade would be nice okay and now I go g6
f5 that just sits that's excellent now
the only thing that worries me is a
night train so it would be five but I
probably is still very solid here to be
honest rupee 3 mp3 is still extremely
solid we should give one to see two now
yeah I've came to a bishop t1 t2 he made
a couple of self weakening moves that
maybe now pay off for me we cannot take
because of rookie to and just lose the
piece
yeah look III is a self-penned so Bishop
t1 is the same for Bishop see true so
Bishop t1 is there drawback to this move
currently don't see itself let's do it
he cannot unpin within one rope with the
tempo so we should see two should win
the pawn still does not necessarily mean
that I'm winning the game so I'll
hanging on here okay still cannot take
so yeah I take now Knight takes I can
take be three so probably should take
this now like Brittany's yeah well I
don't know why actually how many still
can't like King III renter I'm
surprisingly stop which just gives me a
pond because I'm it's just that I'm a
porno so there was no need to resign
immediately ethicals King III and I mean
it's it's a pond but it's not clear that
i'm winning excellent because the
position is so so closed we have you got
seven less sabaki to move by the engine
like here now that's going to be
extremely difficult to win actually
we're as well as hell it's it's it's
extremely solid we have some check and
yeah here this is
22 is much more critical here basically
premium 96 expecting kirinda to life as
it is this is the only critical mode
here the thing is i played this and then
d 65 and after this i returned and what
I can do and black hair now lady six and
d5 without playing the night out in the
first place so I can try to basically
wing to move if white somehow place d5
unprovoked like as one to tempe okay now
we return to to a main line the desired
plate I mean you add with a five at it
inserted a five a 591 h4 that's what I
actually played yeah it's true i played
this one and then h5 see i'm sorry i
confuse the move oil during the game
this is fairly am fairly okay for black
roughly equal you know TM little in the
early age five but it was okay yeah I
don't like this move fyh is weakened a
lot the engine wants to play Bishop to
g4 not lie to G form again i think in
aha f5 no f5 is not a move I I didn't
see this move I mean I understand that
the Queen that the engine gives up the
exchange for multiple takes on my cheeks
wants to go here yeah that's pretty nice
compensation for the exchange why it's
called palm and taking chances and the
way it turned out it was something
really
comfortable for me maybe like here would
be eight to shoot here and the engine
actually liked my plane with want to
play of six he asked all about it but I
wasn't sure ever need to and the doctor
this is fairly nice but so what we got
in the game is pretty much the best that
I can get like be a pawn up or not much
our King at six channel taking haha what
is the point then can I this is what the
engine wants to do red monster I
understand yeah if I get this end that's
fairly nice here because now the pawn on
e4 was always in danger being located
and this is not happening here that
looks very nice yay again he did not
need to resign it all I mean it's it's
tough to to convert and maybe not even
comfortable against best defense ok guys
thanks for watching